foreign
the site of the regular season finale of
the MLB Network showcase Clubhouse
Edition with two of the most electric
teams in all of Major League Baseball
the Los Angeles Dodgers and San Diego
Padres they just happened to play in the
same division this man who was also
making return like mookie best we
haven't seen you Darvish in a while CeCe
yeah I mean he needs to come back in and
set the tone you know obviously this
team is 15 games back now they're in the
you know in the stretch where they
haven't been playing well and you know
he's their guy he's their Ace and you
know me and Petey were talking about
this earlier you know he has to go out
and we feel like he needs to step up and
be that guy put the team on his back and
you know have that stretch of starts and
and try to get them into the playoffs
this La lineup that again has mookie
bets back in it oh man I talked to Mook
the other day it's nice to have him back
in the lineup so nice one two three
start for you Darvish as mookie missed
on that one a little bit his first a b
back off the injured list so still
staring at Donuts through a half cream
what a season it's been for Max surgery
although the one big blemish came
against these Padres July 8th to give up
seven earned runs actually made
back-to-back starts against the Padres
11 runs over 10 and two thirds we got
tatsis back at the top of the lineup
playing right field what I love about
this lineup you see right left right
left right I mean it's it's a steady
balance lineup it's going to be a tough
tough for sure as of today this time
it through
took him nine pitches but he Strikes Out
tattooist open tonight one gone first
inning Jay cronenworth he's got
back-to-back K's to open this one back
footing the breaking ball in prowling
his way around the mound as you said now
faces Manny Machado
oh Max's Max is on one today Max just
came this is what I'm talking about
right here
check my hat check my belt three punches
offense give me some runs first base Run
for the game for either side A lead-off
Walk in the third Austin Barnes will
come to bat the number eight hitter
[Applause]
will have to contend with a guy on
second base just one out Corey Seeger
coming up Seeger hooks one down the line
but oh it is
[Applause]
ready to make
A fitting Statics an RBI double for
Seagull and the Dodgers take a three to
nothing lead it was a scorching line
drive off the bat of Corey Seger off the
wall to tease tried to
to decoy a little bit
and let everybody think including Trey
Turner was at second base that he could
catch the ball that was another breaking
ball that
didn't do a whole lot
coming off the injured list first time
in a while against the team he's had a
ton of success against in the LA Dodgers
first three starts three earned runs and
then tonight are ready three earned in
three Innings pitch see why AJ Pollock
has been one of the hottestines
[Applause]
oh get on your horse AJ
style give me the stop sign Dino give me
the stuff
and Cody Bellinger comes up and
Bellinger with a Fly ball to Right
Center tatis Jr is underneath and he
will make the catch and Paula can skip
home on the sack fly off the bat of
Bellinger for Bellinger's 32nd RPI of
the year and the Dodgers now have a four
to nothing lead back in there against
Darvish four nothing top of the fourth
can opener showcase Clubhouse Edition
diving at first is profar over his
Darvis gets the foot down in time nice
play that's a perfect fundamental play
by the pitcher and and the first baseman
I'll be standing on the mount
everybody understands that this might be
their only chance so the hitters are up
there trying you know extra to deliver
right now because it's like oh we gotta
runs the first and second this this
might be our shop oh wow what a pick
like JT wow
wow but Maxie's gonna give Justin Turner
the biggest hug that game is spoke right
there not getting spoke right there yeah
you don't get Mike surgery in that and
those type of ropes anymore but I think
when you're out there in American League
or national league you understand that
these are Big outs you know what I'm
saying so like it doesn't matter if it's
789 look he's just as excited that's
fired up keeping the Padres off the
board still four nothing L.A come back
for the Showcase this is just a very
thought out you know game plan from him
it's just just been able to execute his
game plan and he's just attacking the
zone so many strikeouts with fastballs
right down the middle and you know I
mean like he's just been able to attack
the Zone which is something that they
needed to do coming off that long game
wrap around your back foot there it is
there's a slider right here
[Laughter]
[Applause]
right here
[Applause]
Sean Anderson the new pitcher for the
Padres
[Applause]
[Music]
I was rooted for him to catch that ball
so I didn't have to hear his mouth
[Applause]
wow what a cat wow
it was worth the catch for me
that's okay
that's right
that's what you did to me too hey that's
how you try you see he turned and looked
at the wall he saw exactly how much
space he had look at his Peak peeks at
the wall he's like oh I got a few more
steps jump time to perfect wow and I
mean that's an amazing kiss
Tommy fam comes up
off of it
look at Joe that was gross that was just
he should be laughing because that was
disgusting wow
nasty four nothing La wins the game
I don't think he called for that chick
I don't know what they're talking about
but it equally paid off it was really
good and Joe Kennedy's like laughing